en un instrumento de cuerda la longitud
de la cuerda déjame llamarle l a esta
longitud es inversamente proporcional a
la frecuencia de sus vibraciones a la
frecuencia le voy a poner f
entonces nos dice que la longitud es
inversamente proporcional a efe de esta
forma podemos escribir a él como una
constante que le vamos a poner acá la
constante de proporcionalidad
multiplicada por el inverso de la
frecuencia multiplicada por 1 / efe muy
bien luego nos dicen las vibraciones
hacen que los instrumentos suenen a eso
está muy padre bueno sigamos una cuerda
de 11 centímetros de hecho esto está muy
padre o sea las vibraciones de la cuerda
pues viajan a través del aire de ahí
llegan al oído en el oído hacen que el
tímpano vibre después eso se comunica
con el oído medio con el oído interno y
por allá hay una cierta magia que hace
que oigamos pero ahorita no nos queremos
concentrar en porque oímos si no
queremos continuar con el problema
entonces déjame seguir
y una cuerda de 11 centímetros esto
suena a una longitud la voy a marcar con
amarillo tiene una frecuencia de 400
ciclos por segundo frecuencia en rosa y
nos dicen que encuentra la constante de
proporcionalidad o sea tenemos que
determinar cada
y luego la frecuencia de una cuerda de
10 centímetros otra longitud más bueno
entonces vamos a hacer esto por partes
vale vamos a empezar encontrando la
constante de proporcionalidad y para eso
vamos a utilizar esta información en
esta igualdad lo que nos dicen es que 11
centímetros que es la longitud 11
centímetros es igual acá la constante de
proporcionalidad multiplicada por 1
entre la frecuencia y aquí nos dicen
exactamente quién es la frecuencia nos
dicen que la frecuencia es 400 ciclos
por segundo 400 ciclos
por segundo muy bien entonces lo primero
que tenemos que hacer es despejar acá y
para eso vamos a multiplicar por 400
ciclos por segundo de ambos lados 400
ciclos por segundo aquí a la derecha y
también aquí a la izquierda 400 ciclos
por segundo segundo y justo la idea de
hacer esto es que del lado derecho se
cancele este con este y nos quede que
acá que acá es igual a esta
multiplicación 400 por 11 pues 400 por
10 es 4.406 4.400 y déjame seguir con
las unidades para que veamos que todo va
bien entonces sería ciclos por
centímetros sobre segundo ciclos por
centímetro sobre segundo muy bien
entonces observa que a partir de aquí
podemos reescribir esta igualdad ahora
sí con el valor de acá podemos poner que
la longitud es igual a 4.400 4.400
ciclos por segundo no ciclos por
centímetro
segundo
y eso tenemos que multiplicarlo por 1
sobre la frecuencia por 1 sobre la
frecuencia muy bien ahora con esto en
mente lo que nos piden es la frecuencia
de una cuerda de longitud 10 centímetros
entonces ahora podemos utilizar esta
igualdad conociendo el valor de l y de
ahí despejar
efe vamos a hacer eso entonces sabemos
que l ahora es 10 centímetros entonces
sabemos que 10 centímetros es igual a
4.400 4.400 ciclos por centímetros sobre
segundo ciclos por centímetro sobre
segundo multiplicado por 1 sobre la
frecuencia
por 1 sobre la frecuencia entonces voy a
multiplicar ambos lados de esta igualdad
por la frecuencia para que me quede del
lado izquierdo y además voy a dividir
entre 10 centímetros para que se cancele
esto 10 centímetros y aquí entre 10
centímetros muy bien entonces que nos
queda este se cancela con este las
frecuencias con esta frecuencia se
cancelan vaya se hacen un 1 centímetros
se va con centímetros y 4.400 es entre
10 es 440 de esta forma nos queda que la
frecuencia la frecuencia es igual a 440
440 ciclos ciclos por segundo y esto
está súper bien porque ciclos por
segundos es una unidad de frecuencia
bueno vamos a meditar un poquito que
sucedió al principio la cuerda era de 11
centímetros y la frecuencia era de 400
ciclos por segundo y después estamos
disminuyendo la longitud de la cuerda
pero la frecuencia aumentó a 440 ciclos
por segundo entonces en efecto pues aquí
en el fondo hay una relación
inversamente proporcional
bueno espero que te haya gustado nos
vemos hasta la próxima